So the Trump tax documents are starting to
filter out and it's instantly terrible for
Donald Trump.
The evidence of financial fraud that we believed
for years was exactly what tax documents would
reveal.
Now, this is not Donald Trump's tax returns.
I know that there are people who maybe misunderstood
the headlines around this.
This is not Trump's tax returns.
Pro Publica has obtained some Donald Trump
tax documents and they show exactly what we've
predicted for a long time, which is that Donald
Trump is playing very fast and loose with
the value of assets and profitability that
he claims depending on whether he's trying
to impress a lender or avoid taxation.
Specifically, ProPublica has documents that
relate to a, they relate to, I believe it's
for Manhattan buildings that Donald Trump
owns.
And they obtained these documents through
freedom of information act requests.
And the documents were provided because, uh,
these documents were made public because Trump
appealed his property tax for the buildings
in question every year for, in some cases,
nine years in a row.
And so what ProPublica was able to do, very
solid investigation was take the tax records
and compare them with loan records, uh, that
Donald Trump's lender, ladder Capitol made
public when they sold the, the debt.
But this isn't just generally saying to a
lender, Oh, my building's worth 50 million.
And then saying to the IRS, the building's
only worth 25 million.
That is something I'm sure Donald Trump is
doing.
A and Michael Cohen told us that that's what
Donald Trump is doing, but this is actually
more Donald Trump is actually lying about
how much rent the buildings are taking in,
which is a much more calculated and specific
type of lie.
Some might call it fraud, and in fact, the
number of real estate professionals are calling
it exactly that.
So here's one example.
Donald Trump told his lender that the buildings
earn twice as much rent.
That one building earns twice as much rent
as what he told tax authorities in the same
year in 2017 okay?
Both can't be true.
Those are lies.
This is financial fraud.
Another example, Trump's building at 40 wall
street.
I would walk by this building every day because
our a David Pakman show studios in New York
city, we're like a block from Trump's building
at 40 wall street.
I'd walk by it every day.
Trump told a lender that 40 wall street went
from being 59% leased to 95% leased in a period
of a few years.
But then around the same time that he was
telling the lender it was 59% least, he told
tax officials that the building was 81% leased.
Now we're still trying to figure out what
the advantage to doing that is.
There may be a disincentives to have empty
buildings, although I need to research a little
more about New York city, a tenant, landlord
law and restrictions and provisions.
Uh, but whatever the impetus was, it doesn't
make sense.
And that's what's immediately revealed by
these documents.
Sometimes the exact motivation for the discrepancies
is not completely clear.
Does he want a stronger position to receive
money from a lender?
Does he want to minimize tax liability from
the, uh, from the, uh, government, the state
government of New York?
But in other cases, it's not totally clear
what the impetus is for each lie, but ProPublica
went with everything that they uncovered to
a dozen real estate professionals and the
real estate professionals were basically unanimous
in their assessment.
Number one, there is no clear explanation
for this, but number two, these discrepancies
are, and this is a quote, versions of fraud,
which would not be a surprise to anybody who's
been following this.
Now this type of fraud can lead to criminal
charges.
It's very unlikely that it will because nothing
has been sticking to Donald Trump.
But note that Trump's former personal attorney,
Michael Cohen and Trump's former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort, are in prison in part
for falsifying tax and bank records, some
of which relate to real estate all in the
service of uh, at least when it comes to Michael
Cohen, Donald Trump.
So this is very serious stuff.
The big picture, the big picture is that this
is called double bookkeeping.
Fraudsters typically do this, they maintain
one set of books.
That's the set you show certain entities and
there's another set of books that is either
your private set of books or the one that
you keep on hand to show other regulatory
entities depending on what is most advantageous
at the time.
Really solid investigation by ProPublica.
And under that, I mean, look, you look at
just a few buildings and it's immediately
clear that something isn't right.
This is just four buildings that they looked
at.
Imagine if we were able to actually get Donald
Trump's tax returns, what might be in there?
His voters might not care.
Sure, but it would be an absolute treasure
trove.
It's almost like Trump knows that his tax
returns going public would be absolutely terrible
for them and possibly implicate him in crimes.
So he's going completely out of his way to
do everything you can to prevent their release.
Exactly.
As we've been saying for years back all the
way since before he even started the general
election debates against Hillary Clinton in
the 2016 campaign, will we ever see the tax
returns?
I don't know.
I don't know, but I hope
that we do.